a deadly shooting in New York City
caught on camera after a suspect rushes
at officers with a knife in
hand NYPD just released this video from
August 4th of last year just before noon
that day dispatch received a 911 call
for a man on Roosevelt Island acting
violently with a knife the suspect was
later identified as 21-year-old Zur Ben
zotin six NYPD officers responded to the
call Body camera video shows them arrive
at the apartment
building several officers head into an
elevator to make their way upstairs
where the suspect was reportedly
stained suddenly the suspect gets off a
different elevator and commotion breaks
out CCTV shows what happened from
another angle Ben zoen gets off the
elevator and rushes straight for an
officer with a knife in hand after this
15 shots are fired at ben zoen who was
shot and injured here's the incident
from the perspective of the officer who
was
attacked closes
yeah
um
try here
maybe with multiple officers on the
scene the entire incident was caught
from a few more perspectives including
this
one
open it
close
want lock the
door I
know thought said fling SWAT huh fling
SWAT Oh I thought you said you sweating
funny and funny enough theer doesn't
[Music]
have silly
we've stopped the video here before any
shots are fired but you can clearly see
Ben zoten has a knife in his hand yet
another officer's body camera captures
the same moments from another
angle
I
know no said I feel like I'm SWAT huh
like I'm SWAT Oh I thought funny if
funny enough theer doesn't have a
[Music]
SW
silly
police Ben zoen was taken to the
hospital where he was later pronounced
dead investigators has found his knife
on the scene and right now the shooting
is still under investigation highspeed
chases we got unruly suspects I will
kill that mothers me no do it stay in
the BL box I like dramatic DUI I'mma
pass everything that she trying to do
and shocking body cam footage hey get on
the ground get on the ground law on
crime presents body cam the place for
real raw and wild police videos you
should have seen it it was good it's on
body camera I'll show it to you catch
the action and subscribe to our new
YouTube channel
[Music]
now no one's going to blow you up no
one's going to you know shoot you you
don't want to hurt you all right
right all right this right here is an
open
room another deadly officer involved
shooting in New York City this time on
December 14th the body camera video of
the incident was just released I don't
know how many times I can tell you that
or how many different times I can tell
you that we're not going to kill you all
right I promise what is that get the
back
NYPD officials were called to Eldridge
Street in Manhattan to track down
43-year-old Kent Edwards who was wanted
in connection with a shooting officers
on the scene spoke to him for more than
2 hours but he continued to act erratic
and refused to come outside body camera
video shows officers speak with Edwards
assuring him he will not be hurt
ishmail we're not going to kill
you all right that's the robot that
robot going to blow me up no it's not
cuz if it blows you up it's going to
blow us up too as officers continue to
reassure Edwards he opens fire hitting
an officer in their protective vest and
another officer in their
shield no one's going to blow you up no
one's going to you know shoot you you
don't want to hurt you all
right all right this right here is an
open room the fuck
in all investigators later determined
Edwards fired four
shots the entire incident was caught on
another officer's camera too and it
shows the shooting from another
perspective tell you that or how many
different times I can tell you that
we're not going to kill you all right I
promise what is that get the back
ishmail we're not going to kill
you all right that's the robot that
robot is going to blow me up no it's not
cuz if it blows you up it's going to
blow us up
too no one's going to blow you up no
one's going to you know shoot you we
don't want to hurt you all
right this right here open I got it well
clear just push
sh hard a third officer's body cam
captures the shooting from another
perspective going to kill you I don't
know how many times I could tell you
that or how many different times I can
tell you that we're not going to kill
you all right I promise what is that get
back
ishmail we're not going to kill
you
all right that's the robot that robot
going to blow me up no it's not cuz if
it blows you up it's going to blow us up
too no one's going to blow you up no
one's going to you know shoot you we
don't want to hurt you all
right all right I got it got
it this shooting is also still under
invest investigation and once that's
complete it will be turned over to a use
of force review board reporting for long
crime I'm Sierra Gillespie